[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
[تصفيق]
تصاعد التوترات في اسرائيل نتنياهو يدعو
لتجنب العنف ووزير الامن الداخلي يدعو
انصاره لتظاهرات مضاده
[تصفيق]
نتنياهو يبلغ الائتلاف الحاكم بعزمه تعليق
التعديلات القضائيه والمعارضه تصر على
استمرار الاحتجاجات
الكرملين يصر على خطته النوويه في
بيلاروسيا رغم تحذيرات وتهديدات من الغرب
مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من التوترات
المتصاعده في اسرائيل طبعا بسبب خطه رئيس
الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو لتغيير النظام
القضائي رغم ان التقارير الاسرائيليه تشير
الى ان نتنياهو ابلغ قاده الائتلاف الحاكم
عزمه وتعليق التعديلات القضائيه والتي ادت
الاحتجاجات ادت الى اضرابات وهي تعتبر
الاكبر ضد الحكومه من اجل تراجعها الا ان
قاده المعارضه يبدو انهم دخلوا في مرحله
اللاعوده حيث قرروا عدم العدول عن
احتجاجاتهم الا بعد الغاء التعديلات لا
بعد تجميدها طبعا خوفا من تحول التظاهرات
لمواجهات بين المؤيدين والمعارضين
للتعديلات القضائيه المثيره للجدل نتنياهو
دعا المتظاهرين للامتناع عن العنف وفي
تغريده على حسابه عبر تويتر شدد على ضروره
اي تصرف المتظاهرون من اليمين واليسار
بمسؤوليه
قبل ذلك دفع نتنياهو عن خطته لتغيير
النظام القضائي قال ان حكومته تواجه حمله
دعائيه سلبيه مشيرا الى ان المحتجين
وطنيون لكنهم لا يفهمون الاصلاح الذي يدعو
اليه وذكره قناه 12 الاسرائيليه ان مقربين
من نتنياهو نصحوه بالتعجيل بخطابه الذي تم
تاجيله اكثر من مره لمحاوله تهدئه غضب
الشارع حيث من المقرر ان يعلن عزمه تعليق
التعديلات
ورغم دعوات نتنياهو للتهدئه وايضا لتجنب
العنف الا ان وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اتمار بنك في ردعه انصاره الى
تنظيم مظاهرات مضاده وذلك في القدس فيما
وصل عدد المتظاهرين بمحيط الكنيسه الى 80
الفا بحسب ما اوردت الشرطه الاسرائيليه في
غضون ذلك هدد ناشطون من اقصى اليمين
باعمال عنف ردا على الاحتجاجات بينما دفعت
شرطه القدس بمئات من قواتها خوفا من
اشتباكات بين مؤيدين ومعارضين للتعديلات
القضائيه
من جانبه دعا ايضا وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي رئيس حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه
بتسئيل
انصاره الى التوجه للقدس مشيرا الى ان
مسار اصلاح النظام القضائي وتعزيز
الديمقراطيه يجب الا يتوقف
اصلاح النظام القضائي وتعزيز الديمقراطيه
يجب ان لا يتوقف تحت اي ظرف نحن الاغلبيه
ويجب ان لا نستسلم للعنف والفوضى والرفض
نحن الاغلبيه لنجعل صوتنا مسموعا سنلتقي
الليله في القدس امام الكنيست ساكون هناك
على كل المزيد معنا من القدس مدير مكتب
العربيه في فلسطين زياد حلبي اهلا بك زياد
اخر المعلومات والتطورات وهناك تصريحات
ايضا لافته للرئيس الاسرائيلي تفضل
هذا صحيح جدا ميسون طبعا نحن في منطقه
الكنيست لكن على الجانب الاخر من المظاهره
التي بدات تتفرق شيئا فشيئا القرار الذي
اتخذ من قبل منظمين الاحتجاج وصل العدد
الى 115 الفا وفق الشرطه الاسرائيليه في
هذه المظاهره في محيط الكنيست القرار كان
بضروره
فض هذه المظاهره قبل ان تكون هناك مظاهره
لليمين منعا لمواجهات بين الطرفين هذا كان
قرار منظمي الاحتجاجات رايناهم يبداون
بالتفرق شيئا
صحيح الرئيس الاسرائيلي يحاول تحت مظلته
عمليا ان يقنع نتنياهو بضروره اعلان وقف
تام لهذه التشريعات
والخوض حوار ربما حتى في مقر الرئاسه بين
الاطراف للتواصل الى توافق ما وفق الراجح
حاليا نتنياهو بات شبه مقتنع بان عليه ان
ليس تعليق
التشريعات حتى ما بعد الاعياد اليهوديه اي
فقط شهر من الان لان ذلك لن يفيده على
الارض الاحتجاجات ستستمر ربما لن يذكر
امدا زمنيا لهذا التعليق او التجميد سيقول
بانه في الوقت الراهن يوقف التشريعات ما
قد يفهم على انه وقف التشريعات في محاوله
ربما ليرى كيف تكون رده الفعل لدى الشارع
الاسرائيلي الغاضب بالاضافه الى ذلك
التاجيل المتكرر جاء لامرين الامر الاول
محاوله من نتنياهو الان مجتمع مع اسمه
لتسويه الخلافات معهما
لانفير يريد ابلغ نتنياهو بان بانه يفكر
في الاستقاله من الحكومه لكن على ان يبقى
الحزب داخل الائتلاف اي لا تاثير على واقع
الحكومه لن تسقط بهذه الحال
ويشترط عدم حدود ذلك بان يعطيها نتنياهو
نوع من الانجاز يسوق يمينيا
لتفسير لماذا تم وقف التشريعات الخاصه
بهذه الخطه للانقلاب على نظام القضاء في
اسرائيل
لا يوجد لا اعرف هو يريد من نتنياهو ان
يعطيه انجاز انجازا حاليا لا يبدو ان هناك
اي انجاز العكس صحيح هناك الان ضربه داخل
الائتلاف وهناك الان ضربه في الشارع
الشارع افلح في فرض اجندته على بنيامين
نتنياهو والحكومه
والامر الاخر نتنياهو ينتظر مظاهره اليمين
اعتقد بانه يريد ان يرى كم سيشارك في هذه
المظاهره ان كانت بضعه الاف هذا يعني بان
موقفه ضعيف جدا
وسيخ تماما للشارع الاسرائيلي ان كانت
بعشرات الالاف الامر سيغاير يستطيع ان
يناور وان يسوق التجميد على انه وقف وما
الى ذلك لكن المراقبين يتساءلون في
اسرائيل كيف نجح نتنياهو في ثلاثه اشهر
بعد انتصار جارف في الانتخابات ان يصل الى
هذا الوضع ان يوحد المعارضه ان يؤلب
الشارع الاسرائيلي باغلبيته ضده ضد هذه
الخطه وان يعرض الائتلاف الى شبه انهيار
في خلال ثلاثه اشهر طيب سنتابع التطورات
طبعا زياد والتفاصيل والاعين الان على
تظاهره اليمين لنرى فرض العضلات من اي جهه
من القدس مدير مكتب العربيه في فلسطين
زياد حلبي شكرا جزيلا لك
هذا ويبدو انه وزير العدل يريف لفين ابرز
المدافعين عن التعديلات القضائيه يبدو انه
ايضا تراجع خطوه للوراء قال انه سيحترم اي
قرار يتخذه نتنياهو بشان مستقبل التشريع
المثير للجدل مضيفا ان الافتقار الى
الوحده في الحكومه يمكن ان يطيح بها وحول
عزم نتنياهو تعليق التعديلات قال لمن انه
اقتنع بامكانيه اتخاذ هذه الخطوه مشيرا
الى ان اصرار كل فرد في الحكومه على موقفه
سيؤدي الى اسقاطها وانهيار الائتلاف
الحاكم
مع ذلك تشير تصريحات المعارضه انها لن
تتراجع زعيم المعارضه اكد ان الاحتجاجات
لن تتراجع حتى يكون لاسرائيل الدستور
مكتوب اضاف ان المتطرفين في حكومه نتنياهو
اخطاوا الحسابات خلال محاوله تمرير
التعديلات القضائيه مشيرا الى ان
التعديلات يجب ان تتوقف وبشكل نهائي
وبجانب الاحتجاجات هناك سلاح اخر بيد
الرافدين هو الاضرابات اعلن الاتحاد العام
لنقابه العمال الاسرائيليه تنظيم اضراب
عام للضغط طبعا على الحكومه حتى تتراجع قد
يشل قرار الاتحاد الذي يمثله اكثر من 700
الف عامل العديد من القطاعات نتحدث عن
البنوك عن النقل الى العاملين الصحيين
وايضا اجزاء كبيره من الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي
بالفعل اعلنت النقابات الطبيه عن اضراب
شامل في القطاع الصحي وبالتزامن اعلنت
لجنه العمال في مطار الدوله عن ايقاف حركه
الملاحه الجويه بالمطار طبعا تضامنا مع
الرافدين للتعديلات التعديلات القضائيه
اثارت غضبا عاربا ايضا في مجالس طلاب
الجامعات وايضا المدارس ولكن رغم كل هذا
الاعتراض من قطاعات عده ما زال نتنياهو
باقي على جوهر التعديلات القضائيه قال ان
حكومته تواجه حمله دعائيه سلبيه وضخمه
الخامسه مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
الشجره باعتماد توقيت صيفي وشتوي دون اي
تعديل الاعمال في لبنان يتراجع عن قرار مد
العمل بالتوقيت الشتوي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه من التصعيد
بين الغرب وموسكت نتحول حول
نيه الاخيره نشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في
بيلاروسيا اشار المتحدث باسم الاتحاد
الاوروبي لشؤون الخارجيه والسياسيه
والامنيه الى ان الكتله الاوروبيه ستتخذ
الاجراءات اللازمه اذا اكدت السلطات
البيلاروسيه نشر موسكو لاسلحه نوويه على
اراضيها قال ان هذه الخطوه سيكون لها
عواقب وخيمه وستزيد من وتيره التصعيد
خصوصا وانها تمثل تهديدا للامن الاوروبي
طبعا هذا الرد الاوروبي جاء بعد ان اكد
المتحدث باسم الكرم لاند متري سكوف اكد ان
موقف الدول الغربيه لا يؤثر على خطط نشر
اسلحه نوويه في بيلاروسيا اشار بسكوب الى
ان الرئيس بوتين اوضح تفاصيل خطط موسكو
ومنسك المتعلقه بنشر اسلحه نوويه
وفي هذه الاثناء اظهرت الصور تدريبات
عسكريه اجرتها بيلاروسيا على الدفاع الجوي
[موسيقى]
لم تتوقف موسكو عن وعيد الغرب حيث قال
سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي نيكولاي بتروجيف
قال ان موسكو لديها الاسلحه لتدمير اي
عدوله وتعرضت للتهديد بما في ذلك الولايات
المتحده كما اضاف ان دول حلف الناتو باتت
طرفا اساسيا في الحرب وهي تسعى لتقسيم
الاراضي الروسيه
[موسيقى]
المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رفائيل جروس سيزرى محطه زابوريجيا
النوويه في اوكرانيا رفقه
الرئيسى على ضروره الحفاظ على السلامه
النوويه للمحطه التي شهد محيطها توترات
كثيره في اوقات سابقه ومنذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا
وفي محاوله لرفع الروح المعنويه للجنود
تفقد مواقع على خط المواجهه هناك في
زبولوجيا قال زيلينسكي انه تشرف بلقاء
الجنود في الجبهه مشيرا الى انهم يدافعون
عن اوكرانيا وعن سيادتها مؤكدا ان قوات
بلاده ستنتصر بالتاكيد
مشاهدينا ميدانيا وخصوصا في مدينه افديفكا
ذات الاهميه في دونتس شرقا يبدو ان هناك
جبهه اخرى بخلاف باخمه تتجه اليها الانظار
وصف رئيس اداره المدينه الوضع بمشهد من
افلام نهايه العالم وذلك بعد ان اجل مجلس
المدينه عمال البلديه جراء كثافه القصف
الروسي وفي هذه الاثناء قالت القوات
الروسيه انها حققت مكاسب في المدينه من
جهته اعلن مسؤول اوكراني بالمدينه مقتل
اثنين واصابه 29 اخرين جراء القصف الروسي
على المدينه كما اشار الى تضرر عده مباني
ومنازل ايضا
في المانيا اصيبت المطارات وايضا محطات
الحافلات والقطارات بالشلل وذلك في جميع
انحاء البلاد هناك هذا اليوم وذلك خلال
احد اكبر الاضرابات منذ عقود مما تسبب في
ارباك ملايين الاشخاص في بدايه اسبوع
العمل هذا الاضراب ياتي في وقت تعاني فيه
المانيا وهي صاحبه اكبر اقتصاد في اوروبا
تعاني من التضخم طبعا الاضراب المقرر لمده
24 ساعه دعت له نقابات عماليه وهو الاحدث
في اضرابات مستمره لشهور اضرت بالاقتصادات
الاوروبيه الكبرى حيث اثر ارتفاع اسعار
الغذاء والطاقه على مستويات المعيشه وقد
علقت ناني من اكبر المطارات في المانيا
وهما ميونخ وفرانكفورت الرحله الجويه في
حين الغت الشركه المشغله لخدمات السكك
الحديديه رحلات المسافات الطويله
المزيد معنا من برلين مراسله العربيه
راغده بهنام اهلا بك راغده انقل لنا
الاجواء من عندك
اهلا بك يا ميسون نحن في محطه القطار
الرئيسيه في برلين هذه المحطه هي عاده
يعني تعج بعدد كبير من المسافرين الذين
يتنقلون ليس فقط بين مختلف المدن
الالمانيه ولكن الى مدن اوروبيه اخرى
اليوم منذ الصباح يعني كل القطارات حركه
القطارات كانت متوقفه هذه القطارات التي
تتنقل بين المدن ومع ذلك كان هناك بعض
المسافرين الذين اتوا وهم يقولون بانه لم
يصدقوا بانه هذه هذا الاضراب سيعني بانه
حركه اضراب كامل او توقف كامل للقطارات
لانه بالفعل يعني هذا تحرك غير مسبوق هنا
في المانيا هي المره الاولى التي يكون
فيها تحرك يعني كبير على هذا المستوى لانه
ايضا حركه الطائرات حركه المطارات
باستثناء مطار برلين يعني كلها كل
المطارات الكبيره من فرانكفورت الى
ميونخ كلها توقفت عن الحركه وعلى ماذا يتم
التفاوض راغده الان في مفاوضات لحل الازمه
او لا او من الصعب وتاثيرها بالمقابل
في الواقع هناك جلسه مفاوضات تحصل اليوم
منذ الصباح بين النقابتين اللتين دعتا
لهذا الاضراب وبين شركات يعني الشركات
القطارات وشركات المطارات وما الى ذلك
المفاوضات جاريه منذ الصباح على زياده
الرتب او يعني رواتب الذين يعملون في هذه
الوظائف في سكك القطارات والمطارات
النقابات تطالب بعشره ونصف بالمئه جوده
على المرتبات نقابه اخرى تطالب ب 12% حتى
الان لم يتم التواصل الاتفاق كان هناك عرض
يعني تقدمت به الشركات وتم رفضه من قبل
النقابات ولكن الان يبدو ان هناك ربما
تفهم اكبر من ناحيه يعني تقديم ما الذي
تطالب به هذه النقابات بعد هذا الاضراب
اليوم لانه بالفعل يعني كان هناك شلل
تقريبا شبه تام في كل انحاء المانيا يعني
ليست ايضا حركه الطرقات تاثرت لانه كان
هناك اطفال لبعض الطرق السريعه لانه ايضا
الموظفين الذين يعملون على الطرقات
السريعه شاركوا في هذا الاضراب لذلك هناك
الان يعني النقابات تقول بانها تامل بان
يكون هناك اتفاق وسنتابع التطورات طبعا
الان لم يتم التواصل بعد شيء من برلين
مراسله العربيه راغده باهام شكرا جزيلا لك
لم يكن الوضع افضل حالا في فرنسا مقارنه
طبعا بالمانيا اغلق متحف ابوابه امام
الزوار وذلك بعدما دخل موظفه في اضراب
للمطالبه بالغاء اصلاح نظام التقاعد الذي
اعدته الحكومه واكدت اداره متحف اللوفر ان
هذا الاضراب جاء كجزء من التعبئه المستمره
للعاملين في مجال الثقافه ضد اصلاح نظام
التقاعد المثير للجدل
شتوي بعد الجدل الذي اثر حول القرار رئيس
الحكومه نجيب ميقاتي قال ان بدا العمل
بالتوقيت الصيفي سيكون منتصف ليله
الاربعاء الخميس المقبل قرر المجلس
الابقاء على قرار مجلس وزراء رقم خمسه
تاريخ 20/8
باعتماد توقيت صيفي وشتوي دون اي تعديل في
الوقت الحاضر ويبدا
توكيد جديد مساء الاربعاء منتصف ليل
الاربعاء الخميس القادم لان بذلك اضطررنا
ان ناخذ فكره 48 ساعه لبعض الامور التي قد
صلحوها او قاموا باجراءات معينه نتيجه
المذكره السابقه اعطينا وقت لاعاده
تعديلها
يوجد لسور القدس سبعه ابواب مفتوحه واربعه
مغلقه لكن باب العمود اكبرهم واكثرهم شهره
ويعد الباب الرئيس المؤدي للمسجد الاقصى
يتزين في شهر رمضان بالفوانيس والاضواء
ويتوافد مئات الالاف من المسلمين اليه حيث
يعتبره الفلسطينيون ارثا وطنيا
ومتنفسا لهم في هذا الشهر الفضيل
[موسيقى]
هنا باب العمود اضخم البوابات الرئيسيه
للبلده القديمه بالقدس بارتفاع يبلغ
ثمانيه امتار
5 من حيث الزخارف ويعود اسمه الى الفتره
الرومانيه حيث تم وضع عمود من الرخام
الاسود يصل ارتفاعه ضعف ارتفاع الباب في
الساحه الداخليه وتم استخدام العمود كاداه
لقياس بعد مسافات الدول والمدن عن مدينه
القدس وللباب اسم اخر اقل تداولا هو باب
دمشق لانه كان الباب الذي تخرج منه
القوافل التجاريه الى دمشق
وللباب اجواء رمضانيه خاصه حيث يتزين
بالاضواء والفوانيس ويتوافد عشرات الالاف
من المسلمين للدخول من هذا الباب وصولا
للمسجد الاقصى ويجلس المئات على درجات باب
العمود لتناول الحلويات بعض الافطار من
البسطات او حتى لتناول وجبه السحور قبل
الفجر لا نكل غاصي من القدس العربيه
[موسيقى]
وبتقرير القدس نصل الى نهايه الخامسه طبعا
مشاهدينا لمتابعه ملفات العربيه وايضا
المزيد من الاخبار والتحليلات تابعوا
موقعنا على الانترنت العربيه دوت نت ورجاء
مسح الكود الظاهر على الشاشه الخامسه
انتهت شكر للمتابعه مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]